[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
war eigens guten abend und herzlich
willkommen alles wichtige vom sport gibt
es von sven voss von mir auch einen
schönen abend unsere großen themen heute
neue corona regeln im herbst der
bundestag stimmt für eine masken pflicht
den medizinischen einrichtungen und
fernzügen
kampf gegen die hohe inflation die ezb
hebt den leitzins um 0,75 prozentpunkte
an das ist die stärkste zinserhöhung
seit einführung des euro und
sorge um gesundheitszustand der queen
die königliche familie zu ihrem landsitz
nach schottland
masken und tests ja lockt eine
schulschließung nein so sehen in aller
kürze die neuen core ohne regeln aus die
ab oktober bis anfang april nächsten
jahres gelten sollen noch muss der
bundesrat zustimmen
heute gab es schon mal der bundestag
grünes licht mit klarer mehrheit
christian hübscher mit den einzelheiten
386 abgeordnete stimmten mit ja 313 mit
nein 3 enthalten sich eine ziemlich
geschlossene ampel mehrheit setzt sich
gegen eine ziemlich geschlossene
opposition durch der gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen ein wochenlanges
feilschen um die korona maßnahmen für
den herbst zwischen dem justiz und dem
bundesgesundheitsminister ist damit zu
ende der eine gibt sich zufrieden egal
was kommen wird ja was das szenario zum
schluss sein wird wir werden diesmal
sehr gut vorbereitet sein und ich kann
jetzt schon sagen wir werden im herbst
die lage gemeinsam im griff haben mit
der vorbereitung die wir ja der andere
betont was man mit den heutigen
änderungen alles nicht beschlossen habe
keinen lockt uns keine
betriebsschließung keine schulschließung
keine demonstrationsverbote und egal wie
häufig man es auf twitter behauptet es
bleibt eine lüge meine damen und herren
bundesweit wird nun am ersten oktober
eine ffp zwei masken pflicht gelten in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen in
arztpraxen in fernzügen aber nicht mehr
in flugzeugen weil dieses masken aus dem
flieger erst kurz vor schluss ins gesetz
kam wird lauterbach von der opposition
hart kritisiert sie haben uns genau
beschrieben wie die lobbyisten von der
lufthansa ag zu ihnen in die
bundesregierung gekommen sind und gesagt
haben ja das ist alles so schrecklich
kompliziert wären sie denn im
fernverkehr das personal ist nicht
belastet mit der durchsetzung der massen
pflegt absurde diskussion über die
masken pflicht in flugzeugen versus
maske pflicht in der bahn das was wir
erlebt haben waren 80 seiten
änderungsanträge vor der finalen
ausschusssitzung wenige stunden vorher
über alle weiteren maßnahmen entscheiden
künftig die länder abhängig vom
infektionsgeschehen und der bundesrat
muss dem gesetz noch zustimmen
angesichts der energiekrise und der
inflation sagte wirtschaftsminister habe
ich heute vor allem kleinen und
mittleren firmen unterstützung zu
saerbeck steht seit tagen in der kritik
gerade wegen seines plans alle drei noch
laufenden atomkraftwerke vom netz zu
nehmen und zwei davon in reserve zu
halten
angriff ist die beste verteidigung sagte
sich habe ich nun offenbar in der
haushaltsdebatte im bundestag
patrizier wiedemeier
es läuft derzeit nicht wirklich rund für
den wirtschaftsminister steigende
energiepreise eine stark kritisierte
gasanlage ein umstrittener kurs bei der
atomenergie die kritik vor allem aus der
opposition heftig heute nun schlug er
verbal zurück vor allem richtung union
16 jahre energie politisches versagen
und wir räumen in wenigen monaten auf
was sie in 16 jahren kaputt verhindert
und zerstört gestritten wird vor allem
um den weiterbetrieb der zwei atommeiler
im süden der wirtschaftsminister will
darüber erst im winter entscheiden es
gehe nicht um wöchentliches an und
abschalten so habeck die opposition
fordert den weiterbetrieb aller
atommeiler in jede kilowattstunde zählt
dann zählt auch jede form jede form der
möglichen energieerzeugung die hier in
deutschland möglich ist die letzten tage
haben doch klar gezeigt dieser minister
und diese regierung sie können das
einfach nicht wir werden regiert von
energie politischen geisterfahrer bei
allem streit es gab auch gute
nachrichten heute für kleine unternehmen
wie zb diese bäckerei aus hamburg soll
es hilfen geben vorausgesetzt die
produktion ist energieintensiv und der
konsum geht zurück wir schaffen das so
einfach nicht mehr dann ist ja nicht nur
jetzt der gaspreis oder bzw strom der
strompreis sondern es sind natürlich
auch noch die löhne hierüber
insbesondere der mindestlohn und die
steigenden rohstoffkosten ab oktober
soll es auch für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen einen rettungsschirm geben
kündigte der wirtschaftsminister an dass
für die preise runter bekommen haben
werden wir den unternehmen jede hilfe
zukommen lassen wir werden einen breiten
rettungsschirm aufspannen
schadensbegrenzung für die wirtschaft
und für das eigene ansehen keine leichte
aufgabe in diesen zeiten für robert
habeck
eine andere große energiequelle
sonnenlicht da hat dieser sommer der
wärmste bislang gemessen in europa die
erzeugung kräftig angetrieben noch nie
ist in der eu so viel solarstrom
produziert worden zwischen mai und
august kamen zwölf prozent des stroms
von der sonne dafür hätte man gas im
wert von 29 milliarden euro einkaufen
müssen so hat es die denkfabrik amber
kleinbild errichtet der anteil von
solarstrom lag in deutschland bei 19
prozent das ist platz zwei hinter den
niederlanden
ja die steigenden preise dieses thema
besorgt die menschen zurzeit wie kaum
ein anderes die europäische zentralbank
ist unter druck heute nun hat sie erneut
den leitzins angehoben und zwar um 0,75
prozentpunkte auf 1,25 prozent
das ist die größte zinserhöhung in der
geschichte der notenbank
im august kletterte die inflation in der
eurozone auf die rekordhöhe von 9,1
prozent
ziel der zinserhöhung mittelfristig die
teuerungsrate zu senken darauf setzen
auch viele unternehmen ihre hoffnung
mehr von stefan schlosser
verschiedenste kabellösungen und
schaltschränke unter anderem für große
solaranlagen die firma hek solutions in
südhessen liegt in rund 60 länder
weltweit endlich die inflation in der
gedämpften das fordert geschäftsführer
berthold entrup
wir haben massiv gestiegene energie- und
materialkosten diese preissteigerung
müssen eine änderung noch können wir
diese preise weitergeben aber
mittelfristig könnten wir eine vielzahl
von kunden verlieren wofür unsere
mitarbeiter geht es langsam an ihre
existenz auf diese dramatische
entwicklung reagiert die ezb erst im
juli hatte die zentralbank die
jahrelange nullzinspolitik beendet heute
legt sie nach der leitzins steigt um
0,75 auf jetzt 12 5 prozentpunkte in
dieser höhe ein historischer schritt
wir gehen davon aus die zinsen weiter
anzuheben da die inflation viel zu hoch
bleibt und wahrscheinlich für längere
zeit über unserem ziel bleiben wird
die präsidentin selbst räumte heute
fehler bei der einschätzung der
inflationsentwicklung 1 diese einsicht
kommt nach ansicht vieler deutlich zu
spät es kann nur der beginn einer
leidenschaft seien die zinsen weiter zu
erhöhen um die inflation klein zu
kriegen um mir das genick zu brechen
denn inflation frisst kaufkraft auf und
kaufkraftverlust sorgt dafür dass in der
rezession stattfinden wird die
wirtschaftsaussichten sind düster das
weiß auch berthold entrup die frage ist
aber wie düster es werden wird
jetzt nach großbritannien dort hat sich
der gesundheitszustand von queen
elizabeth der zweite offenbar
verschlechtert die ärzte zeigten sich
nach mitteilung des königshauses sehr
besorgt über den zustand der 96 jährigen
noch am dienstag hatte die königin auf
ihrem sommersitz in schottland lässt
schwarz zur neuen premier ministerin
ernannt
mitglieder der königsfamilie eilten im
laufe des nachmittags nach schottland um
in die nähe zu sein
andreas stammen london wie ernst steht
es um die queen
ja man muss sagen es ist wohl äußerst
ernst es war eben diese presseerklärung
des buckingham palasts um 12 uhr
ortszeit die alle mehr als nur
aufgeschreckt hat diese formulierung
besorgt über den gesundheitszustand der
queen die ist äußerst ungewöhnlich denn
normalerweise gilt in sachen
gesundheitszustand der königin
verschwiegenheit das ist privatsache es
sei denn es ist eben ernst und dieser
eindruck hat sich dann über den tag
deutlich verstärkt zwei ereignisse
erstens im parlament gab es heute eine
große debatte da wurde der plan
vorgestellt die hier die in der
energiepreis krise bekämpft werden soll
150 milliarden und plötzlich war enorme
unruhe denn sowohl die premierministerin
als auch der oppositionsführer bekamen
zettel gereicht und danach war die
debatte quasi beendet und zweitens eben
die ganze familie hat alles stehen und
fallen gelassen die noch nicht in
schottland war und ist eben nach schloss
balmoral gereist und selbst harry kam
also es ist sozusagen mehr als nur ein 1
anreisen das dürfte ein abschied nehmen
sein und die queen ist ja auch schon
länger gesundheitlich angeschlagen hat
ja auch bereits einige amtsgeschäfte
abgegeben
ja dass das drama um die queen um ihren
gesundheitszustand das geht ja jetzt
schon sehr lange sie hat eigentlich alle
pflichten was ihre außen repräsentation
angeht an prinz charles abgegeben und
der auch ja sie jetzt jeden tag
getroffen hat in den letzten zwei drei
wochen was auch ungewöhnlich ist das
heißt er ist voll geschäftsfähig er kann
die geschäfte der queen weiterführen
auch in diesem zustand er ist nicht
regent daran dagegen hat sich die queen
immer gewehrt weil sie gesagt solange
ich geistig rege und fit bin kann ich
diesen job eben machen auch aus dem
sitzen auch aus dem palast auch über
videokommunikation aber ich glaube diese
tage sind jetzt gezählt und hier das
gefühl ist warten alle auf eine
ankündigung des palasts er falls das
neue entwicklung gibt in dieser sendung
werden wir wieder zu ihnen scheiden
dankeschön an resta
zum ukraine krieg mit weiteren waffen
und der ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten
wollen die verteidigungsministerin und
minister der sogenannten ukraine
kontaktgruppe das land weiter
unterstützen deutschland und die
niederlande planen vor allem beim thema
minenräumung zu helfen über das treffen
auf dem us-luftwaffenstützpunkt ramstein
thomas reichert als der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister in ramstein landet
hat er zwei dinge dabei das versprechen
neuer waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
im wert von über 6 175 millionen dollar
und die forderung an europa sich
vorzubereiten dass die hilfe für die
ukraine noch sehr lange dauern wird
heute muss diese kontaktgruppe zeigen
dass sie die ukraine langfristig
unterstützen will und das bedeutet den
kontinuierlichen und entschlossenen
fluss von militärischen fähigkeiten
die usa kündigen deshalb weitere
lieferungen von artillerie und munition
an um die ukraine bei ihrer
gegenoffensive zu unterstützen
deutschland verspricht helfen unter
anderem bei der minenräumung aber es
bleibt beim nein der regierung zur
lieferung von schützen- oder leopard
panzern die in deutschland bereit
stünden panzer sollen andere liefern
und es ist ganz wichtig dass wir die
ukraine schnellstmöglich unterstützen
deswegen gehen wir den weg dass wir die
länder bitten abzugeben was sie haben
außer wird aus beständen sowjetischer
bauart damit eben schnell damit gekämpft
werden kann das ist der schwerpunkt und
wir helfen dann beim auffüllen von
entstehenden lücken bei einem
überraschungsbesuch in tier verspricht
auch us-außenminister blinken heute
helfen im kampf gegen russland 2,2
milliarden dollar für die ukraine und
andere osteuropäische staaten
das gesicht des krieges verändert sich
und damit auch die aufgabe dieser
kontaktgruppe wir werden
zusammenarbeiten um die ukrainischen
streitkräfte für die langstrecke
auszubilden ob allerdings auch europa
diesen langen atem hat das wird sich
erst noch zeigen müssen
im un sicherheitsrat gab es einen
heftigen schlagabtausch über den vorwurf
das russische militär verschleppe
menschen aus dem ukrainischen
kriegsgebiet nach russland schätzungen
zufolge seien so zwischen 900.000 1,6
millionen menschen aus ihren heimatorten
deportiert worden sagte us-botschafterin
thomas greenfield russland wies die
beschuldigungen zurück
die ukrainische armee geht in immer mehr
regionen zu gegenangriffen über
teilweise offenbar mit erfolg in der
nähe von haag konnten die truppen nach
eigenen angaben 50 kilometer weiter auf
russisch kontrolliertes gebiet
vordringen und 20 ortschaften
zurückerobern in der region bonn jetzt
zwingen die kämpfe immer mehr menschen
zur flucht über die situation am bahnhof
von prokop rechten an ginzel und thomas
konsum
von kuczkowski auskennt der zug nur noch
einen weg richtung westen ganz gleich
welchen alters ganz gleich wie
beschwerliches ist sie sind gekommen um
zu fliehen nur weg aus dem don bass
heute wurde auf jahns ständig beschossen
ich habe ein paar sachen eingepackt und
bin weg erzählt uns der 17 jährige
alexander die einschläge kommen näher es
gab eine gewaltige explosion c3 straßen
von meiner wohnung
viele die den zug nach knieproblemen
haben ähnliches erlebt abteile voll mit
verstörten traumatisierten menschen
engagiere im krieg
aion flieht mit seiner frau und drei
kindern er sagt in kammerforst nimmt der
beschuss zu die not der menschen ebenso
humanitäre hilfe eingestellt
lebensmittel teuer und knapp
wir wollen nicht dass die kinder in
angst leben sie sollen keine explosionen
mehr hören müssen und ein irgendwie
normales leben führen normalität weit
entfernt noch ganz nah das leid juba
flieht zum zweiten mal
ich war schon mal mit meinem sohn
geflüchtet für drei monate aber ich
hatte heimweh als wir zurückkamen
beschossen sie uns wieder
und nun ungewissheit angst auch hoffnung
dann fährt er los der zug mit
passagieren die ihr bisheriges leben
zurücklassen um weiterzuleben
nach einer serie tödlicher
messerangriffe in kanada ist nun auch
der zweite tatverdächtige tot er war
seit mehreren tagen auf der flucht und
starb nach seiner festnahme im
krankenhaus nähere angaben machte die
polizei nicht sein mutmaßlicher komplize
und bruder war bereits anfang der woche
tot aufgefunden worden weil den
messerattacken am sonntag starben zehn
menschen 18 wurden verletzt
die hintergründe sind immer noch unklar
so jetzt kommen wir zum sport mit
champions league sehr licht und schatten
bei den deutschen teams oder svenja
niederlagen gab es für frankfurt gestern
und leverkusen der fc bayern aber
präsentierte sich in absoluter champions
league form beim ungefährdeten sieg
gegen inter mailand war einer nicht zu
bremsen die mitgereisten fans mindestens
ebenso begeistert von matchwinner lira
äußern wie dessen trainer der ja ohnehin
von sany schwärmt die zwei tore oder die
ja die sektoren auch die zweite aktion
macht es schon weltklasse sehr gut drauf
legt und super kontrolle wäre es extrem
schwer zu verarbeiten gemeint ist diese
ballannahme mit name und verwertung zum
führungstreffer ende 25 minute schon
krimis langer pass ein augenschmaus der
in der vergangenheit häufig kritisierte
sany veredelt ihn kam weniger schön sein
doppelter doppelpass mit kommen in der
67 minute für jeden bayern für ihn ein
treffer seines offiziell aber ein
eigentor von d'ambrosio
gestern wurde trainer domenico tedesco
bei rb leipzig nach schwachem
saisonstart entlassen heute wurde
bereits der neue vorgestellt fußball
lehrer marco rose unterschreibt einen
zweijahresvertrag bei den sachsen der
gebürtige leipziger soll den aktuellen
dfb pokalsieger wieder in die
erfolgsspur führen erster gegner am
samstag ist roses ex-club borussia
dortmund
die deutsche basketball
nationalmannschaft geht als favorit ins
wm achtelfinale am samstag gegen
montenegro gegen ungarn begeisterte das
team noch einmal im kölner hexenkessel
dann ging es weiter in die hauptstadt
grau der himmel über berlin aber die
spieler strahlten innerlich da keine
überzeugenden vorrunde mit vier siegen
umzug für schröder und co dem kapitän
wurde beim ungarn spiel schon zeit
gegeben was der spielfreude keinen
abbruch tat den sieglosen ungarn diesmal
keine chance auf die neuen im team
punkteten fleißig in der breite ist der
kader gut aufgestellt für das ziel em
medaille wäre schon zufrieden sein das
richtig gemacht wir haben wichtige
spiele gewonnen und sind einer guten
ausgangsposition jetzt für die für die
ko runde ein paar lockere würfe zum
auftakt in berlin erst morgen beginnt
dann die gezielte vorbereitung auf das
achtelfinale gegen montenegro
deutschland ist favorit
tja und soeben gemeldet schlimmer
ausschreitungen vor dem conference
league spiel der kölner in nizza ein
schwerverletzter fan der anpfiff wurde
vorerst um eine stunde verschoben nicht
gut
vor über fünf jahren verließen der
frühere us präsident barack obama und
seine frau michelle das weiße haus nun
sind sie wieder eingezogen mit ihren
porträts gut gelaunt scherzte obama der
künstler habe seine bitten ignoriert ihn
weniger graue haare und kleinere ohren
zu verpassen die rückkehr ist ein happy
end für die obamas denn eigentlich hätte
die enthüllung schon in der amtszeit von
tom sein sollen doch der bruch mit der
tradition und lud sein vorgänger nicht
ein
jetzt noch kurz zum wetter der kräftige
regen im nordosten des landes zieht
heute nacht ab morgen erwarten uns dann
einzelne schauer und gewitter genaueres
gleich von christa oben marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um 21 45 zum heute journal
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend es gibt ihn noch den
verbreiteten regen auf den wir den
ganzen sommer gewartet haben der
satelliten film von heute mittag zeigt
uns die wolken dazu und zwar ist das
hier dieses kompakte wolken band das
gehört zu dem tief peggy das hat seinen
dreh zentrum hier bei den britischen
inseln wir sehen über tag sind diese
regenwolken nach nordosten gezogen was
jetzt folgt in höhen kalter luft sind
einige quellwolken heute nacht gibt es
im südwesten aus denen auch schon
einzelne schauer und gewitter sonst ist
es aufgelockert aber in
schleswig-holstein
mecklenburg-vorpommern brandenburg und
berlin schüttet ist noch richtig in der
ersten nachthälfte vor das ganze dann
nach nordosten abzieht dazu sinken die
temperaturen auf 14 bis 8 grad am
alpenrand
morgen erreichen wir dann 17 bis 24 grad
also keinen sommertag mit über 25 grad
mehr dazu ist es vormittags wechselnd
bewölkt einzelne schauer haben wir schon
in der westhälfte das wird über tag dann
aber mehr dann wechseln sich kurze
schauer und gewitter ab mit trockenen
vielleicht auch sonnigen phasen also es
ist so richtig aprilwetter im september
herbstlich ist dabei der wind der
stürmer aus südwestlichen richtungen
auch am samstag bleibt es noch
unbeständig am sonntag haben wir die
reste im südosten schon am montag wird
es dann wieder trocken und kurzzeitig
wärmer